O ne o
[Müzik]
ki buyurun da var mı
bu yumurta sarısı hızlandırıcı yerler
vardır
Selam bugün benim doğum hayata doğduğu
andaki gezegenlerin hepsini gösteriyorum
pis neler hayatımızdaki faaliyetlerini
anlatıyor böyle boyundan büyük laflar
edip bilmiş bilmiş konuşmayı sevmem ama
hayat tecrübelerini alacağız tertiplere
engel olamaz mıyız 60 sadece değil tabii
ki enteresan ilginç şeyler var Bir
düzeltelim de ön eklediğim Aslında benim
bu sohbetlerin şu an sahibi Konuşmayıp
yapmamı destekleniyor ama diğer taraftan
da başka gezegenleri
Bu da böyle çektiği için sonra komşumuz
ayıp Bu arada Merhaba
ben hepiniz hoşgeldiniz
konuşmak özellikleri arasında olmasada
tercih etmeyin
olabilir bunu yapabilmek için o
[Müzik]
a harfi yaparım hafızası yaparım yeni
farklı varsa girişi öldürmeler veriyoruz
seversen de görebiliyoruz
Ne anladın efsane taharetsiz yaptım Onun
altındayım bir barda çok sayıda farklı
iş alanlarında çalışmış biri olarak şunu
söyleyeyim ki bir değişimini ne en büyük
şansı Sahip olduğunuz ki kadar
Allah yolunda kesiştiği insanlar
olduğunu düşünüyorum bunlar her zaman
iyidir deyince
pozitif insanlar olmayabilir bazen
yanlış insanlarını da yolunuz kesişiyor
tercih bu evlerimize oynadığı ufak bir
oyunu Bu benim gibi Bu salonda bulunan
herkesin en iyi Hayatının bir döneminde
kadın geniştir diye düşünüyorum ya da şu
kişide karşılaşmasaydım hayatım bambaşka
olurdu yerler var mı aranızda
görebilir miyim
bu tahmin ettiğim gibi çoğu zaman bugün
geriye baktığında geldiği noktada diğer
taneye dört geçmeye borçlu olduğunu
görüyorum en önemli en sonda anlatacağım
Çünkü her birinize yolun bir onunla
kesileceğini Rüzgar dönüyorum
mi Evet
biliyordum dört gelişme İyi ki
beni döven
matematik böyle dedim
herhalde oyun varsa üstündeydi
üniversiteye hazırlanıyordum hepsi olmak
istiyordum bir gün
ders sırasında çok basit bir problem
çözelim ve öğretmenim böyle Sırıtma
Sağlı oturuyordum bu çok hızlı bir
şekilde geri rahatsız Sen Diye vurdu
aldı matematik gelişe gitti
sonrasında özel basket dersleri bıraktım
Bu karar sonrası değişim garantili olsun
diye hemen buradan bir bölümüne yöneldi
Aslında Hayat olmak istiyordum ama annem
bana zorla çok az öğrencilerin gitmesin
olabildiği Japon dediğini yazdırdı şimdi
konuşabilen çok insan olduğu için de çok
para kazanıp sevgili olacağımı hayatını
kurtaracağını söyledi bana Ben de
inandım anneler böyle ederim izlediğiniz
isterler ve garantili bir yaşam her
zaman acısı onun tercihidir Sonuçta
tahmin edeceğiniz gibi Japon dedin
kazandım orada derslerden hiç
anlamıyorum o kadar zor ki 20 yaşında
Saçlarım beyazladı ve o günlük boya
başladım ve mezun olduktan sonra o da
çok olaylı ol bu daha sonra anlatacağım
Bir Japon yaşadım inanılmaz gereğince
verilecek Türkiye gözlüklü sefer mi
yapmaya başladım kızlarım babasıyla bu
iş sayesinde tanıştım evlendim görmek
çocuk doğurdu bugün bakınca
matematikten Vazgeçtim Dünyamız benim
için dünyanın en mükemmel iki evladına
sahip olma arzusu delik diye düşünüyorum
bunun içinde bana geri zekalısın diye
örnekleriyle şimdi buradan çok teşekkür
etmek istiyorum
ilginç karşılaşma bir kelebek etkisi ydi
buna böyle şey birisi vermek istiyorum
sağlam bir kazık sonrası bu muhteşem
buluşma Mason yazarımı ana olduktan
sonra hızlarının buraya getirip götüren
doğum günü partilerinden çıkmaya
sihirbazları film kahramanı ezbere bilen
bir anı olarak Bu
hayat böyle geçmez
çalışmak istedim
ne
ile ilgili şeylerdir istiyorum o dönemde
İstanbul'da çok önemli balık restoranı
var
ben onu ortak olmak istedim
sahibi tek şartı olduğunu söyledi altı
ay mutfakta Altay'da salonda çalışma
ya da hiç öyle şey
yapmıştım Tamam dedim ve bu farklı
çalışmaya başladım böyle aylarca
buralarda ısırgan otu ayıkladım elim
şişti kare zayıfladım 5 gibi balık
Okuyorum yani hepsini düşünürseniz ve
Android tekrar çıkmış o yüzden son kızım
sonuçlarını derdinde değilim bebeğim de
Hiçbir ortak noktası olmayan erkeklerin
arasında bambaşka bir dünya değil evde
ben her geçerken
tane başında mevcut bir evde yaşayan
vesaire arkadaşımızı bu İlginç at
saldırıya uğrayarak şey geliyor gel
diğer genişliği ise biriktirdiği tavan
arasındaki paralarınızı fareleri
yediğini falan anlatıyor
Yok aşkım ya çok sevdiğim insanları ile
birlikte bir kilisesinde bildim
etrafı malin neden orada olduğunla
ilgili hiç tahinli yoktu anlamıyorlardı
da biraz da dalga geçiyorlardı öyle
yazıp oluyor sana diyenler ojen
bozulacak değişim vardır burda giden
izleyenler neler neler geldi Çok
enteresan the ama bir taraftan da böyle
çok sevdiğim bir şey yapıyorum ama sanki
dünyamıza karşıma almış gibiydi bile
dağılmadığı Çünkü yaptığım işle ilgili
çok mutluydum Önemli olan sevdiğim şey
yapmadı
mu
buldum son bekliyorsunuz yazıyorsunuz
çok çalışmama rağmen hiçbir şey
planladığım gibi gitmedim
ortamdan Maddi manevi çok büyük kazık
yedim Şimdi mama anlamıyla Yakında benim
için o dönemde Ama yediğim bu kızın beni
çok büyüteceğim Ee ve hayatının dönüm
noktası olacak başka videoda
götüreceğine dair habersizdim
16 nasıl bir şey yapmak istediğini
biliyorum
o kızları Mamını bırakacaktım
yurtdışında pastacılık eğitimi alacaktım
ve Türkiye'ye böyle bir pasta Dükkanı
açmakta
hayalini oluştu Daha sonra bir daha
düşün görmedim ya arkadaşımla karşılaşma
hayatımı değiştirdi cm'e al onu da
hayatındaki Misyonu oymuş
arkadaşım benim yapmak istediklerimin
Birebir aynısını yapan yardımcı olduğunu
söyledi ve bizi tanıştırdı
bu Evrensel xalanın mükemmel zamanımız
bu kadar hızlı kelime rağmen İçimden bir
ses bu sefer işlemi gidecek diye
güvendim ve ve hiç tereddüt etmeden bu
yeni ufaklığa geldim ortağım ben ve bir
personel ve üç kişilik küçük bir
hastalık ya kurdu öyle yeni bir işe
girişmiş iz çok hevesli Siz çok
çalışıyoruz her şey deniyoruz ama bir
türlü para kazanamıyoruz
e herkese sağlıyoruz ofisimizde çalışmak
istemiyor şu an Türkiye'de hemen hemen
her sokakta hepinizi çok iyi bildiğini
uluslararası kahve zincirleri o zaman
Türkiye pazarına yeni biliyor ve fazlası
var
biz de istiyoruz onlarla çalışmak ama
çaldığımız kadar hep böyle suratımıza
kapanıyor ve seyretmiyoruz başka bir
fikrim ile karşılarına çıkıyoruz bu
kadar tehdit ki
neredeyse kapılarında yardım Neyse en
sonunda bir tanesini sözleşme imzaladık
başardı kendini sonunda
dediler ki sizin ürünlerinizi taze
doludur yapabiliyor musunuz
daha fazla yapıyoruz cevap var
o Çünkü biz Adana'da İstanbul dışında
altında da
şubeler açacağız buralara o pastalardan
böyle bilirsiniz olarak
değil dedim
en iyi anlaşmazlığı vallahi babam fazla
çalıştık bir ne oldu
Bu bir şekilde Yaşasın ile değiştirdik
örnekte böyle yaptın adlı doldurduk ama
bir sağlamadığınız bir şey vardı o da
pastalar şeyle elinden nasıl geçirdi
bu dünyanın en güzel şehirlerinden biri
izleyebilir çok iyi ürünlerini
İstanbul'dan diğer illere gönderiliyor
böyle gider yere yetkilisini Saldırdım
yağıyorum Ama gördük bu tür
Sizin eviniz götürürken şok diyorum bir
köşeye bizim okuttu hastamız var
bunlarda taşırsanız ne olur diyorum
yetkili mümkün değil diyorum diyorum
expressive anlaşmalarımız Var Ceza
şartlarımız var vesaire Ama adam o kadar
bekledim ki en sonunda hızı ya da benden
Bu da da bir şekilde Tamam deriz Böylece
dolu fazlalarını Türkiye'yi dağıtılmaya
başladı mi
ve
batılı bir de tabi işi
İstanbul'daki pastalarını sattığınız
tarafı var
en iyi günlerimiz personelimiz yok
paramız yok çünkü böyle çok seven
insanların evlerine doğum günü ve
düğün pastalarını döküyoruz
şirketimizin 19 90 model biri Kartal
arası var bu kadar utanıyorum ki orada
fazla için arayıp çözümü böyle bir de
var da uzak arka Sokağı farkedip
hastaları taşıyarak teslimat yapmayı
buldum Çünkü Düşünsenize neredeyse
neredeyse yani pasta İndira
araba bin 500 lira daha bize teslimatı
yaparken bizim duruyorum sanıyorlar
Tabii ki doğal olarak
tipimizi görünce böyle bir tereddüt
ediyorlar Hani bahşiş vereyim mi
vermeyeyim mi o lütfen baş almaya
bayılıyorum
şirketi o kadar parasız ki o kadar
ihtiyacımız var ve bahşişleri havada Bu
yazılım
o haddi aşanları ortam dolaştım
rotasyonu dağıtıyorum buyurdu böyle
bahşişleri yarış yaptırıyorum Sen ne
kadar başarılı olduğunu ben kadar
topladım diye
şişman şişerken seslerle değil büyük
oluyor ve para gelecek dedi
o tilki ben seni işte Benimle çalışmak
istemiyorum Ben seni çocuklarla
İlgilenmek istiyorum dedi ve ona destek
olmalı Peki ben ne yaptım artık beni
Almadın ki arabayı sattım ve orayı
şey yazacağım
en uzun süre
dolmuşlarda hayatım geçti
bugün o zaman yine de aynı şeyi yapardım
diye düşünüyorum sonrası film gibi biraz
çekim gibi üç kişiden kişiye 51 ve üstü
metrekareye ulaştığını Türkiye'deki çok
mü hepimizin bildiği markaları dolup
çizgi ve pasta üreten ve dağıtan bir
fabrika ediyoruz tahmin ettiğinizden
daha çok işler büyüyünce
ne çıkan fırsatı değerlendirdik ve
arkamızda çok ölü bir Türkiye'nin en
büyük dolumu şirketine sattık
ama bazen başka bir ilmek gibi bırakmaya
girmem gerekiyor çünkü Bence hayatta her
başlangıcın bir sonu olduğunu
düşünüyorum
bu ve
en yeni gelişme
Ben bunu biraz evde Sağ ol ve
sahurda ediyorsunuz olma Nadir olan
şeylere üniversiteden mezun olmama sebep
olan kişi
destek olan kişiliğin aynı işi Bence
bazen insanların hayatımızdaki yerleri
çok farklı ve çok başka Sadece bu
örnekte bile kimi kesişmeleri
etkilerinin ördük olduğunu göreceksiniz
Japonca konuşmadım sizden tek kalmıştım
Sonra da izin vermiştim okula gittim
o
imanın vaktim yok sana şu an slime'ı
kalınca akşam evde telefondan alacağım
sana anlattıklarımı daha sonra diğer
Japonların fena telefonda
açıklayacağız yağmadığını
Bu oyun vardı şeyler oldu iş değil yani
Benimki tahtına kesin alacağım
telefonunuzdan olur
bu sırada Ya arkadaşım eve döndüm ben
ağlıyorum yani bitirdiğinde benim
olamayacağını emilecek üzerinde Japonca
anlayamıyorum doğruyoruz teknolojide
sıkıntı o
telefonda mümkün değil o zaman geçmeyi
düşünüyorum ve çok üzgünüm
arkadaşım aradığında ona da anlattım ama
ağlıyor biraz daha da o da böyle biraz
da vardır hallederiz
Ben dedim Aslında buçukta kalktım
yeneceğiz Ya ben hani iyi bulamayacağız
diye düşünüyorum yarım saat sonra bu
çaldı ya da evde olup olmadığını sordum
ben Tepeyi çıkarttım Fatih çıkartmaz
işte bir açtı içinde telefon açtı onu
bağlı falan
sonra konuşmalar kayboluyordu
bu sınav zamanı geldiğinde telefon çaldı
yeter yetmezse diye o kadar çok
korkuyorum ki Çünkü kaybetmezsiniz
olamayacağım biraz da böyle
birlikte
kaydediyor Çünkü ben olamıyorum
bu ve konuşma bir tane gitmez
beni sever verilenlerden dininizi varmış
ve astım ve yaptım Bir kaydetmişti
bilmiom mezun oluyorum
O çok şükür hepsi kaybetmiş ve böylece
üniversiteden mezun oldum bugün
baktığında olmayacak niye şu an kadar
Allah'ım He çok şeyin gerçekleşmesini
vesile oldu hayat çok garip Bence her
şeyde birbiriyle bağlantılı
Ben uzun olduğum Evlendim Çocuk doğurdum
boşandım hazır gece iş kurdum işi
devletin derken Tüm bu süreçlerde
arkadaşımla bağımlısı pompalı için 13
bunları yaşarken hep böyle hepimizin
çocuğunuzun hayatını daha böyle bir
sahil kasabasında yaşamak istiyorum
kelime böyle birileri Faruk bile
konuşmama Nasıl yapacağımızı bilemiyorum
taraftan yine üniversite zamanında
olduğu günkü gibi Tam ihtiyacım olduğu
anda aradım çok enteresan bu defa cep
telefonundan konuşuyoruz her zaman
geçmiş tahmin edelim dedi ki bunu da
aldım ve projede sana ihtiyacım var
başında olmanı istiyorum dedim hayatım
gerçek olmuştu Ben burada öldüm
ve o içinden çok gerçekçiyim çok önemli
Team her şeyde bir mantık çerçevesinde
bakıyorum bunu rağmen bu gönülden
istediğiniz şeyler için ağrının
birilerinin görevlendirdiğini inanıyorum
yürekten inanıyorum ve herkese mutlaka
karşılaşmasını bildiğin son kesmem
gördüğüm gücü olan Bugün beni yapan
kendim
ve tüm hataları yaptığım yanlışları
rağmen her sabah uyandığında gördüğüm
kadına yükleyebilmek için hep çok
seviyor tamam ve beri hep insanların
karşılaşmam gerekiyormuş burada
sağlamaya çalıştım işler onlardan sadece
birkaçı
bu
adam büyüme
bu haftası olan diğer cin rehberlerine
de burada teşekkür etmek istiyorum
hikaye burada böyle bittiğini düşünmeye
taşıyorum olmadığına eminim
en yeni kararlar almak yaşamı
değiştirmek bunun için adım almak bir
doğanda var bugün burada mutlu olsam da
yarın ve Meraklı bir ileriye götüreceği
ile ilgili hiçbir fikrim yok Ama bir gün
Dünyanın bir ucunda tatil yaparken Siz
mesela
bugün doğum günü
ne olur ya O benim önce işte sen
o bana benziyor ya
çalışıyorum
dertli bir kadın misiniz lütfen adını
sorun açayım sakın şaşırıyorum
ayrıca bizim beğenemedin mi
[Müzik]
[Alkış]